the total wealth of high-net-worth
individuals or the top 1% is more than
fifty six trillion dollars and that
number is expected to grow the 2015
world wealth report was released by camp
meanie RBC and RBC Wealth Management
last week and we were we've been looking
through it Betty and I here and we are
fascinating with me to me is just how
many of these people there are right i
mean there's what something like over 4
million 14 globally globally so there's
almost 4 million here in the US almost
15 million people globally that have
fifty six trillion dollars I was
thinking it would be cool if they just
bought their own like country or island
and they they all went there you know
and left the rest oh no income
inequality in this world huh wouldn't be
except for that one island right okay so
I the you no surprise the u.s. is the
biggest is a place that has the most
number of we have almost five million
exactly i'm here millionaires but angel
sixteen trillion dollars by the way so
those people could all go to their own
city they could all go to you know
Bentonville Arkansas and live there and
had their own super wealthy city cuz i'm
sure that's on the top of their list of
where they want to go really it's a very
nice nice but eight but I was just gonna
mention that Asia is number two and
fastest-growing and you can imagine
right why that is I mean almost every
day you hear about a new billionaire
uncovered and India interestingly enough
has has the fastest growing segment of
millionaires uber wealthy but maybe they
won't all stay there if they go to my
ethical islands you have an island that
you want to sell but I would be willing
to be a servant I thought you might have
a valid or that you may want to sell I
would park cars for them I mean that's
it to me the only thing interesting
about being that wealthy is the amount
of cars that you could buy but I'm sure
there's other stuff I've been reading a
lot about the art art that people buy
like Stimac long pain I would hope that
if you're that wealthy you might want to
put that money to good use other once
you satisfy your your your your guy
having a story and a social you know our
goal here